now you may think sharks are scary
but not in the warm waters of Grand
Bahama in the Caribbean where it's
lunchtime for Caribbean reef sharks
and what's got over two and a half
million internet viewers buzzing is this
the divert appears to put the sharp to
sleep and that does something even more
bizarre
yes she's balancing the shark on its
nose or is she okay shop balancing no
one is gonna do that this cannot be real
is this real or is it not balancing a
shark on his nose how could you do that
the best person to tell us whether she's
a heroine or a hoaxer is scuba CRO
Cristina's annatto this clip that you
see is real and hundred-percent and I'm
the person in the clip I want people to
stop and go oh wow I did not know sharks
could do that and maybe I can educate a
little bit more about the true nature of
sharks so how does Cristina get the
shark to balance on its nose
Cristina is stroking the shark and it's
picking up on the electrical charges
from her chainmail glove interacting
with the water and it sends it into a
sort of hypnotic state scientists call
it tonic immobility where it seems to be
trying to be relaxed so much so that she
can tip it up and balance it on one hand
in other animals tonic immobility is a
last resort it's a way of playing dead
when they're being hunted but in sharks
because they're top predators no one's
really sure why they do this
christina is manipulating the shark's
sensory perception the Sharks have got
these very very fine pores in their nose
which enable under sends electrical
signals from other animals around them
the way that they detect these electric
fields is through something called the
ampullae of Lorenzini their canals that
are lined with hair a little bit like
the human ear leading down to a gel
filled chamber which is surrounded by
nerve cells they're very very sensitive
so by gently stroking the nose of the
shark you're as over stimulating this
this system I like to think the shark is
really getting off on this remember
christina is an experienced shark
stroker so don't ever try this or you
could end up as the main course I don't
think anybody can do this I think it
takes the right combination of the right
person with the right shark at the right
time and the right conditions and no it
won't harm the shark